good oh yeah there we go good morning
John I just wanted to take you down to
the Clark Fork River which is close to
flooding right now but I want to start
this to you by asking you a question
what were you thinking when you gave
yourself a punishment because that Wow
and now you have to because of the Helen
Hunt thing yeah I just spat in the river
and Flemmi there's a walking path right
up here
probably people wondering why there's a
guy down here screaming you know it's
downtown there's crazy people over what
is that noise
that was crazy noise oh oh it's a who is
the ice cream truck it's playing
SexyBack ice cream trucks have
apparently grown up a little since I was
a kid so here's something that I think
no one knows ah
baby boys used to be dressed in pink
until the 1940s and baby girls were
dressed in blue it was totally flip
until Hitler but little pink triangles
on gay people during World War two
because he wanted to label them so that
everyone could take the proper
precautions and you know so that he
could later kill them more efficiently
after that pink became an effeminate
color because of Hitler the entire world
switch and that is why pink ribbons are
for boobies because of Hitler log
brothers we teach you things that you
don't know I'm bringing sexy back papa
yeah
don't believe I'm on the side of a river
here's a stick this is not a green
screen people I should throw a rock into
the river so you can see yeah yeah John
punishment idea Corey Vidal wants me to
video in which he annotated it and then
he made people click and then you
clicked on two items that he would then
blend and drink we obviously created the
blending and drinking stuff so I wrote
to Corey and I asked if I could
appropriate that idea and he said
absolutely that's just fine don't stead
of blending nerdfighters you are gonna
make John make a sandwich there's gonna
be six ingredients and you're gonna be
able to click on two of the ingredients
he'll make a sandwich with those two
things put them in between a piece of
bread and then eat them like sprinkles
and bake or pigs feet in marshmallows or
lard and lox lard and lox the Steve
Buscemi story the newest hippest
nightclub in downtown New York is lard
and lost I don't know what John did you
know that the tallest man in the world
once reached his giant arms down the
throat of a dolphin to remove shards of
plastic from the dolphin excelsis arms
were long enough and he was
able to do it in the veterinarian's
couldn't do it only he could did you
know that I bet Shaq could have done it
but Shaq was too busy that day
he's not gonna be so busy anymore
Achilles heel what kind of bad ass as a
bad Achille wait a second
Achilles would be a good example of that
found an aunt in your aunt show yourself
to the video blog the nerdfighters want
to see you hello aunt he's big with a
big aunt Museum museum areas that's
enough of that so that is my view for
one of your punish maybe can be both of
your punishments your punishment has to
be here is two punishments one you have
to make a video that has more than 40
video parts and that would be of 6 6
times 6 is 36 so maybe more than 35 and
your other punishment is to make a lot
of sandwiches with gross stuffing up
nerdfighters leave suggestions in the
comments for things that should be
included in a John sandwich making also
I've been working tirelessly on my new
album which I know it should have come
out a long time ago it has songs that
had been out for ages like strange charm
and what would Captain Picard do but it
also has new songs that you haven't
heard yet like shake a booty and my
phone I'm very excited about it it's
called Ellen Hardcastle of course here
is the cover art that I own the stuff
design very excited yes Phineas gages on
this as well I'm hopefully going to have
it available for LeakyCon if you're
gonna be leakycon I hopefully should
have the album there and then it should
be on sale for on dftba shortly after
that which is like July 13th I think so
I'm very excited about that and Jonna
very excited about watching you eat
sandwiches John I will see you on Black
Friday